and that's how we grew and that's why I
tell people I say to blog I don't
actually mean blog but I meant create
bangers text based bangers uh on a
consistent basis and get people to love
your free content enough to subscribe
TBB baby text based
bangers that's been our strategy right
like how'
[Music]
you all right we're live can I tell you
about a few interesting pieces of
content I've consumed lately and I want
to hear what you've consumed yeah let's
do it the info diet section the info
diet section yeah let me tell you the
first one so I have been on a Scott
Galloway kick Scott Galloway um has a
podcast and I think that's what he's
more famous for than anything but he uh
uh he started a few companies but he's
got this U like one of his companies L2
I think it sold for
like 200 million it was like nine
figures he dude he did this podcast
called Scott's personal finance I found
it on YouTube where he talks about like
money and and like how much money he has
and what's he spend spends it on and he
like he's like this is all going to
sound douchy but I'll tell you he's like
basically I'm worth at least $100
million he goes he goes I made it into
the nine figures recently he said I'm
still incredibly anxious about money it
stems from childhood he's like we were
just poor and I'm super anxious about it
but then he goes he does something cool
he says two things that are interesting
one he goes I'm spending between
$200,000 and $400,000 a month and I
moved to Europe and the guy was like why
would you move to Europe he goes well
America's the best place to make money
and Europe's the best place to spend it
love that that's great yeah it was
awesome he goes he goes look what I've
realized is that I'm I'm getting older I
don't have a lot of time to live maybe I
have 40 more years or something like
that to live I'm gonna spend it and I'm
G to enjoy the hell out of it he's goes
it feels incredibly masculine for me to
be able to provide these experiences for
my family and I'm doing it he says I
spend around $1 to $200,000 a month now
on travel we fly private we went to the
World Cup I brought my uh I brought uh
another couple in their family just
because I wanted to we paid for the
whole
thing and he goes through this like
really like detailed thing about um
spending his money and another
interesting thing he said and I want to
ask this about you so he has had I think
three companies of which one was like a
very big success and that it probably
made him $50 million but he said I've
made more money being on board on the
boards of companies and the equity that
they've given me than actual actually
building companies and what I'm
surprised about is what he said is that
I've made more money doing not my main
thing or at least what I thought was
going to be my main thing doing these
like ancillary things uh has that proven
to be true in your career yet 100% um I
wouldn't say more yet but I've
definitely seen examples of that so I'll
give you a very simple example of my
life and I'll tell you one that was from
a recent episode so um in my life I've I
started an e-commerce company maybe
e-commerce brand three years ago roughly
I can't tell you how many hours I've
spent on this e-commerce thing like it
takes a lot of time to build a real
company that actually has you know real
revenues real profits that are
significant and there's a physical
product tons of energy goes into it I
have pulled out zero dollars and zero
cents from this business now the
business makes a lot of money right
we're tens of millions of dollars in
Revenue but I pull out $ zerar it all
gets reinvested and all my time gets
invested into this thing and it is very
uh labor intensive so I haven't made
much money from this but one thing that
did happen was along the way I was like
ah such a pain like I'm always on my
phone you know like often if you message
me I'll be like oh yeah I'll send it to
you when I'm back at my computer they
like I'm not just like at my computer a
lot and um I wanted to be able to check
on my my my store from my phone and the
Shopify app doesn't really make that
very easy like you can get in you can
maybe see your Revenue but you don't
know how your ad are doing you don't
know how your Amazon store is doing you
don't know how your Google accounts
doing uh you don't know how your clayo
emails are working and so meet these two
uh you know two two Jewish guys who are
like hey we made this thing that's like
a mobile um mobile way to manage your
storefront for any Ecom brand they're
like a we have an Ecom brand we built
this thing for us and I use it I'm like
oh this is great and uh I'm like okay
I'd like to invest and they're like oh
cool like you know I think I maybe the
first investor maybe second something
like that very cheap like $5 million
valuation or something like that do you
remember what you put in $75,000 to um a
company called triple whale was that all
your money uh no this all my investments
have to go through the fund unless it's
like um something that like wouldn't be
eligible for the fund but this would
because otherwise it's like a bias thing
so put it in from the fund um so put
this money in and I'm like uh great I
hope this does well but I'm not sure it
seems like you know maybe just an
analytics widget I don't know it might
not be the biggest thing in the world
but I I think it's really useful for me
I think other store owners will find it
useful start telling other owners about
it blah blah blah this company's now
worth hundreds of millions of dollars so
you know on a five million doll
valuation entry point you know we're up
40x or something like that uh you know
30 40 50x somewhere in that range so you
know SE take
$75,000 and multiply by by let's just
take 40x for a second it's three million
three million bucks now of course it's
the fund so you know my carry on that
20% um you know but it's also not done
this is just like you know a couple
years in if this becomes a two billion
doll company um you know I there's it's
easy to see that I will have made more
and and by the way I invested in six
other e-commerce SAS tools it's like oh
sales tax is a pain in the ass cool let
me use numeral for that this is like a
new startup that's doing making it easy
for e-com owners to a sales tax oh I
need uh bookkeeping and accounting let's
use final Loop instead of QuickBooks
it's like I started investing in a bunch
of these whatever thought was the best
tool after I did the research I was like
well I'm not just going to be a user I'm
also going to be an investor and I just
did that across the board and a lot of
these are are huge now postcript for for
text message like what Ronda Sanz is
using for his text messaging I don't
know what he's using but probably should
be using postcript because it's the like
the best way to send SMS marketing and
you just invest in these because you're
a user but like I've made more money
investing in e-commerce SAS tools than
I've made from my store and the store
took all of my time and these other on
took one hour of emails to back and
forth to just do the investment and
that's like you know not what I would
have expected going in however had I not
done the e-commerce thing I would have
never understood the value of these
tools or been able to see them early or
been able to be like hey let me in and
I'll introduce you to hundred other
people that have stores because I'm in
that Network now and so you made money
in this like not what you plan to make
money you made money in this other weird
way same way Scott Galloway didn't make
you know he makes the money in his
company but then his reputation is where
he gets paid to be on boards way easier
and more money especially when you count
dollars per hour I give you another
example we just did a podcast with uh
Samir from col and Samir and in that he
talks about like they got their start
doing something that like nobody would
look at it be like this is a good
business plan he was like we're gonna
basically I think they were fans of
Lacrosse or La they were lacrosse
players or something and they created
like a lacrosse Sports commentary
Network on YouTube it's like niche of a
niche of a niche and they did this
pretty early on YouTube and honestly it
didn't work that well but it did two
things it taught them about YouTube and
making videos and now their YouTube
channel is like million subscribers it's
a you know it's a multi-million dollar
brand easily um so that taught them that
but also when they were doing that when
they were uh following the lacrosse
scene they saw this one guy he was the
best lacrosse player in the country and
he's like wanted to go pro but there's
like no Pro scene for lacrosse you get
paid nothing and so he's like dude if I
go pro I make $35,000 a year this sucks
he like screw it i'm GNA to make my own
lacrosse league and this guy created his
own Lacrosse League well guess who
became the first investor in the
lacrosse league Samir um because and he
he's like I didn't have a lot of money I
put in whatever I don't know what it was
let's pretend it's 10 grand but like
that lacrosse league is now worth
hundreds of millions of dollars and he
got into the very beginning so like in
this weird way he's gonna make he'll
probably make more have made more from
that one investment than all of the
YouTube action he was trying to do along
the way but it only would have happened
by being in the game and getting giving
yourself that opportunity to get lucky I
think it's called The Arena it's being
in the arena
showard for brown guys like me to say
the arena I don't want to get get caught
in that fire um you could say that he's
in the arena um that's good and and by
the way that podcast was great um the
second thing that I've consumed lately
I've been reading like crazy so you um
you and Andrew kind of got me turn on
this I hate I don't really love love
investing but I uh wanted to to learn
more about it and so I read Warren
Buffett's biography not the one snowball
that's too long it's like a thousand
Pages this one's called making of the
making of an American capitalist have
you ever read uh anything about Buffet
uh I back in the day like 10 years ago I
read a Buffett book but I don't really
remember it to be honest man I didn't
know anything about I didn't really know
anything about him but there's a few
traits about him that are crazy the one
like he's got like this a shuck demeanor
like I'm from the Midwest like what do I
know you know I just super charismatic
he could be president yeah yeah well
it's mostly kind of [__] in a sense
like the guy's a genius like he's like
the 1% the 1% in terms of IQ in terms of
horsepower and there's this crazy de uh
this crazy story where he's like helping
to buy I think it's Solomon Brothers or
no sorry it's ABC uh so he's buying ABC
for multi-billions of dollars and he's
sitting at his desk and they're like all
right let's work out the deal he goes oh
no let's just work it out right now like
and he's like well what about your
analysts like where are they he goes I'm
the computer it's all here and he
doesn't have a calculator he doesn't
have anything like that he's like let's
just we're going to do the deal right
now um and I can just do it in my head
and he just memorizes all these their
annual reports and all their numbers and
then he like does the math in their head
he's like if I Warren goes if I can't do
the math in my head um then I I don't
understand this deal and I probably
shouldn't do it so his IQ is crazy the
second thing is that his discipline is
super strong so before he had birkshire
hathway he had a fund with like I think
it started with
like 100 Grand or something not
substantial but was growing 30% a year
and he did that for like 10 years and in
the 60s he just shut it down and they're
like why are you shutting this down he's
like well I just don't see any good
opportunities right now you know I like
I said I'm I'm looking for good
opportunities I don't see any right now
so I'm just going to shut this down and
so he just doesn't he quit investing had
a little mini retirement he's incredibly
disciplined and then the last thing is
that uh he has super high integrity so
like he's only sued someone one time and
that time was when he gave a guy a a
charity $25,000 and the guy robbed him
of the and he didn't actually provide
the charitable work that's the only time
he sued someone and there was another
time where he was being investigated by
the Senate they thought that he was
insider trading because um he did a few
things that were like smart and he just
made the right calls and after
investigating him for two or three years
they're like hey do you want to like
join this committee on like fraud
because you're really smart and you're
like the most honest guy we've met and
he joined the committee there's another
time where he wants to uh he's like in
this country club and he's like hey why
don't we let Jewish people in this
country club this is pretty ridiculous
and he's like and the guys were like
look the Jews have their own thing they
have their own country club it's 100%
Jewish let the Jews go there so instead
of putting up a fuss about it he goes
and joins the Jewish Country Club he
goes hey they uh integrate and they let
non-jews into their thing I think we
should do that to our thing and that's
like how he goes about doing stuff he's
like not confrontational but he's like
pretty slick um and then the last thing
I guess is he basically for the first
like 40 years of his career he only read
annual reports and that's how he got his
information so people are like how are
you so good and he's like dude I just
read like five annual reports a day and
all the information that I'm using he's
like I don't even have a computer I
don't have a terminal all the
information that I use any one of you
out there can go to a library and get
that same information so super unique
guy so I've been very fascinated with
him but he's got one downside do you
know what is you know he's like a a a
[__] family man right right yeah he uh
he has a very weird a strange family
Dynamic so what Happ so he got divorced
yeah but then she didn't get divorced so
his wife Susie they she was like a
hippie and for some reason he was into
that and they were married and he loved
her and everything but she was one day
she goes you know Warren I just want to
go off to San Francisco and I want to do
my own thing but we're not going to get
a divorce and he's like all right cool
and she goes also I have my friend named
astred she's going to come over and take
care of you I thought sister it's not
her sister it's just a friend it was it
was a like someone she was friendly with
okay and so within a week of ASD taking
care of Buffett of waren they are like
lovers and like she moves in and they
like date however like they're all
friends with each other and so Susie is
like hey as I think you should
redecorate the house from when I did it
it's getting a little old like she gives
her tips on taking care of him and then
like when Buffett has to go to like
these big like presidential public
meetings where he's meeting with senate
or whatever Susie comes when he when she
wants when he wants go and do like some
local stuff or like some some uh stuff
that doesn't require a lot of press ASD
comes and they take turns and every once
in a while if it's like a really big
thing they'll both go and they'll team
up and they'll support him it's very
interesting and it's very strange but
he's not a very present father and he's
super [__] cheap with his kid so
there was a time when his daughter was
living in a really crappy apartment and
she had just had a baby and this one of
Buffett's friends goes to check on her
and the daughter can barely see the TV
because it's a little small black and
white TV and the friend goes Warren you
should buy her a big screen TV man she
has had a baby she's sitting in this
shitty apartment just buy her a [__]
TV and he wouldn't do it he didn't want
to buy her a TV and it like it took him
convincing to he's like I don't want to
spoil them and so he's really cheap and
like it didn't seem like the best father
I like that there's one thing I always
remember about Buffett that uh or like
two things that I really like about
Buffett I have a whole uh doc that I
keep called buffe isms and because he
has this skill of telling like these
like tiny stor these little Parables
that are both funny and interesting and
then make his point for him and I just
feel like he's got an arsenal of these
and so I've been I like I don't read a
lot of his books but I watch a lot of
his talks and I watch a lot of their
like annual shareholder meetings um to
try to find these little little phrases
he uses that I am like oh this guy's so
Charming but also he's he does a great
job of making his point using that um
another one another thing I like about
Buffett is he said one thing once that
really stuck with me he go goes um the
stock market like people like why don't
more people get rich he goes because
they don't really understand how the
game works he goes um the best rule of
this entire game in this with the stock
market is that you don't have to play um
he's like um most people's problem is
that they just do too many things they
make too many Investments they buy and
sell too many things and they feel
constantly compelled to like come to an
answer on should they or shouldn't they
do X and he's like um you really just
have to sit and wait for the fat pitch
you just don't have to do you don't have
to swing that's where you got your fat
pitch thing yeah exactly there are no
called strikes in um in investing like
you could sit there all day and just
watch pitches go by and just wait for
the fat pitch the problem is people suck
at waiting and that really stood out to
me because I'm somebody who historically
is very bad at waiting I'm a very
impulsive impatient person it serves you
well as an entrepreneur to be very
impatient you take a bunch of action as
an investor impatience and impulsiveness
is a terrible trait so as I've shifted
my career to go from entrepreneur to
investor I had to ask myself you what do
I need to relearn what do I need to
unlearn uh what served me as an
entrepreneur that's not going to serve
me as an investor and let me make that
that conscious switch and that was one
of the the key switches that I realized
I had to make and I just and and I agree
that's a that's a a really good lesson
and I think he stole that from um Teddy
Williams like a famous baseball player
who hit lots of home runs and he like
Teddy Williams made this like graph he
just it was a strike zone so it was just
a
and he's like look my batting average if
I hit a pitch in this bottom corner is
pretty low I might make connection with
the with the pitch it might be a strike
but my batting average is low I sh I
really shouldn't even swing at that
pitch even though it's a strike he's
like I'm looking for stuff in The Sweet
Spot because here I'm over 400 right so
he has Ted Williams has the greatest
batting average ever and one of the
reasons why was he was more disciplined
than others in what pitches he would
swing at he would really wait for those
fat pitches whereas most batters get
quite impatient and start just hacking
at everything but my issue with Warren's
advice on that stuff was all right well
what's a good pitch look like and so I
ordered this book that's gonna it's like
they didn't make a lot of copies of it
but so I had to find it on Amazon uh and
it's gonna take like two or three weeks
to come but it's um I like how you just
said Amazon like it's like some Niche
bookstore you went to oh it's hard to
find I had to go to amazon.com to find
it it's this little book this little mom
and pop Boutique um but they uh they
anal all of his deals and they write out
what he saw in them because I'm trying
to figure out okay you're telling me
what a bad one looks like what's a good
one look like and so that's some of the
content that I've been consuming um it's
been good I've been reading like a book
or two a week it's because Kindle you
read on Kindle ever yeah yeah that's all
I read on pretty much I'll I I start on
Kindle and then if I like the book I'll
order the hard cover so that I have it
around the house to just remember it
pick it up whenever I want but I start
on Kindle well they have this like
percentage bar at the bottom where it
says what percentage of the book that
you've read and I'm like I'm going to
get through 20% every night and uh it's
been awesome so shout out to kindall you
got you nailed
it gamified your
ass um okay so let me let me tell you
two things that are interesting
one uh the content I consumed uh so I
listened to this podcast by our friend
uh David senra I don't know that that
well I hung out with him one time and um
he's he's a total nut in the best way
like uh he's a thousand miles a minute
but I want to share with you he did a
pod the other day that I thought it was
really good called uh I think it was
called the greatest interview I've ever
done and it was basically some it was uh
Patrick ranesi interviewing him they're
like what did you notice about a lot
you've studied all these great men and
history right you you read these
biographies and what are some common
things that you see he goes the story of
the sun uh the story of the sun is uh
begins at the end of the story of the
father so basically like uh embedded in
the story of the son is the story of the
father and he's like this is very very
common whether the father was great in
all these ways often you'll see the son
take a totally different approach or if
the father was limiting or hard ass or
uh really brutal in one way the son
takes that trauma and basically uses it
in in what they do and I thought that
was pretty cool second thing he said
about reading that I really liked he
goes um they go do you reread books and
he goes yeah of course I love rereading
books reread books all the time and uh
you know I think a common thing would be
like oh isn't that kind of a waste to
like read what you've already read it's
like you know you've already read that
book it's the same thing why not read
something new and he said it really well
he goes I read books like several years
apart often and he goes um the words are
the same but I've changed he's like you
know I'm a different guy than I was when
I first read that book so the second
time I read it I've had years of life
experience I've read a hundred other
books I've had all these these things
that I've done in my life and now the
same words mean something totally
different to me or I have elevated
understanding or memor memory or
different thing stands out to me I
thought that was a really great Insight
on rereading because I'm a big fan of
rereading like I'd rather find a great
thing and soak in it versus trying to
just move on to the next and count the
number of books I can read in a year and
um I thought the re that that point he
brought up is one that I I really never
uh never heard I also thought that he
did an amazing job of almost like
building his like person story so he
said it really well why did you start
doing this like why did you start this
um this whole thing where you're reading
all these books and you're doing this
podcast like how did you even have the
the inspiration for that he
goes look uh man my my childhood was not
the best like I grew up and uh my
parents did their best but they weren't
necessarily the best he goes I you know
I'm the only person in my family to ever
graduate from high school and he's like
I wanted to be successful but everywhere
I looked around me all I saw was the
wrong answer all I saw was what not to
do I didn't read just to as a hobby for
fun I read because I was looking for the
answers I wanted to know what what to do
because all I saw in my life was what
not to do that's what led me to reading
the biographies of the greatest people
he goes I have spent the last you know
whatever 10 years of my life having
one-way conversations with the greatest
people ever to live on this Earth and he
goes that's what I think about reading
he goes I think reading is having a
one-way conversation with the greatest
people on Earth and he goes and he goes
and the you know the podcast people are
like why' you podcast I don't know man I
didn't even start it he goes this is
just an obsession I am just studying
these people I needed a way to put it
put my thoughts down he goes this is an
obsession disguised as a podcast and I
loved it I was like wow he good these
are great little on line he's very
lyrical with it and so um I'm very
impressed by David C I think he's doing
a great job and uh yeah this it was it
was it was a fun fun thing to to consume
I I joked with them I was like you know
like David there I got turned off on
reading a lot of these books for a while
because I would listen to him on Audible
and I had my favorite narrators and I
would go like oh I love this guy's voice
what else did he read this uh narrate
and this guy has read like a thousand
narrated a thousand books and I'm like
how the [__] is this guy still a
narrator what' you think if you read all
these business books he would be way
more successful that's that's kind of
what I'm bring it up here like I love
the way he phrases things I think it's
really compelling I actually don't agree
with him that like you're not actually
having one-way conversations with the
greatest people on Earth it's not like
you needed to do all of that to be
successful actually you should probably
just get out there and do some things
right like I actually could argue a
bunch of the other sides but what's the
point the fact that he believes that is
going to lead him to a really great and
successful place um I don't subscribe to
all his thoughts but I am a fan of his
level of intensity and conviction in
himself and what he's doing in
California uh like I think in the 90s
they banned weightlifting in the prisons
cuz they're like holy [__] we're
building super criminals these guys are
getting yolked they're like too big and
uh they're like they're they're
surrounded by other criminals they could
like talk about like the best way to do
stuff and now they're and now they're
[__] bench pressing 500 lounds these
are super criminals we got to get rid of
them David is like becoming a Super
criminal a little bit he's like one of
the guys who's like reading it and like
just cranking
away he's plotting David's plotting dude
there's a I feel like I could be like
hey David um he's sitting there reading
a book I'm like David you like that book
he's like [__] love this book what do
you are you joking me and I'm like David
in this room right over here Heidi Clum
is standing there naked she's surrounded
by all the best desserts you could ever
eat Michelin star desserts the the music
it's the greatest music you've ever
heard all of the unreleased Drake albums
are are in here they the you know it's
the best music it's the best party
there's no other guys in here just all
naked supermodels and um David the best
part is when you walk in you become a
billionaire and I think he'd be like he
wouldn't have even heard anything he'd
just be turning the page to the next
next face like this guy doesn't want to
do anything he would have licked his
fingers and just look back down just
heard the page the silence chump I'm
reading and that's the best compliment
and the best insult I can give him at
the same time like I think it is amazing
that he is that way that he's he really
feels like this is the best thing that
anyone could possibly do he can't
believe nobody else is doing this he
doesn't it's like this is the the the
peak of the peak of life experience I'm
inspired by him anything else that
you've consumed that you like uh not a
but I have a different um so in the way
that I'm like by the way I hope he
doesn't take offense I'm joking about
some of these things but like yeah I'm a
huge fan of fan of his stuff and I think
he does an amazing job and I have no
vested interest in his success except
for I think he's really cool and I think
he does a great job I appreciate his
craft and he's one of the few pods that
I like listen to on a regular basis it's
quite good yeah that was like a genuine
endorsement it's called Founders by the
way the Pod is called Founders so we'll
give him a we'll give him some love the
other thing that uh so I'm so the other
interesting experience I had was I Rec
I'm drawn to people like him people who
are slightly extreme who are obsessed
who have a independent mindedness
they're deciding how they want to live
life and they their rubric of success is
different than others right that's what
I just described about him that I like
um Ben had a meeting with somebody and
he comes back he calls me oh dude I bet
this guy he's great he's doing this
thing um and then he just kept say he
like said two or three times like really
great guy and I'm like I I was like man
why is he such a great guy like um
you're only there for 45 minutes like
you know what do you mean by that why
did you you kept saying I really liked
him I really liked him I really like
what he's doing I go do you really like
what he's doing or you really like him
he goes I think I really like him I go
let me guess was he high energy when he
talked a nice guy like simple not didn't
intimidate You by kind of being a hard
ass about anything and uh did he teach
you one or two interesting things during
the conversation he goes bingo I I know
Ben because that's your archetype of
what you really like that's why you
really like me I'm a high energy guy um
I'm I'm a nice guy I don't like you know
I don't like kind of push people into a
place that they feel uncomfortable um
and I'll usually if you talk to me for
an hour you're G to learn one or two
things that's why we get along and um I
said you know one thing we should do as
again how do you become a great how do
you shift from operator to maybe
spending spending more time investing is
I think we gotta uh investigate what are
our bias and our blind spots so
basically we made a little list of
what's the personality archetype I am
rationally drawn towards for me it's the
David senra types it's the slightly
extreme uncomfortable ambition around
their thing independent mindedness um
obsession with their craft I am drawn to
that I will make mistakes you know it's
like a girl who's like ah you know he's
a six but he's wearing a leather jacket
it's like it just does something to me I
gotta go for him like that's what I'm
drawn to and I was like on the other
side what what can't I stand somebody
who's just dry if you have no sense of
humor if you're dry like you could be
the smartest guy in the world sitting on
a gold mine of a business if you're
boring like within five minutes I'm like
this guy sucks I'm out and um you know
I'm just like who's an example of that
like a famous person well dude I'm not
trying to make a you know trying to
famous like a like a or like a someone
who you've read about let's see a public
person I don't know off the top of my
head do you have one who's just dry I
mean um there's like a bunch of like
famous investors and [__] who like I've
read about and I'm like this is news
Fest um like yeah there probably just
like some I don't know Enterprise stas
or these people who are like yeah we
just make the best um or like you know
we just provide uh solid procurement
services to others right it's like I
don't know like they don't have a lot of
hobbies yeah like do you love that like
no but I we we service a need and it's
like cool like so like what are some of
the cool growth hacks you've been doing
they're like well we don't really need
growth hacks we grow 17% year over year
it's like uh we just really need to do
solid operations it's like oh okay I I
just I need to get out of this
conversation right now like I'm I feel
itchy like I got to get out of here
whenever I read about like hedge fun
guys I'm like this is a snoozefest dude
you're just like this like when they do
like a lot of like Fast trading unless
they're kind of like a criminal and kind
of doing drugs then I'm in all way I'm
always down with like I love a good
Crime Story unless you're driving your
your successful life off a cliff I'm out
yeah yeah I need some drama but like
whenever I read about like hedge fun
guys I'm like dude you're just play on
Excel all day I don't find that
enjoyable to hear about but I think I
think it is useful it was useful
exercise for us to do which was what do
you irrationally drawn towards that you
should probably like Dial A Down
discount be able to apply a discount
after the fact when you're when when
when you're out of heat and then what do
you have an irrational distaste for
where you're going to underprice or
underestimate somebody and actually you
shouldn't be um people have been talking
about like bias and like the stuff like
but like they always came at it from
Like A diversity and inclusion point of
you um for me I you know like sure
that's fine but I've never been like
drawn to like
you know I've never been drawn to
spending a bunch of time thinking about
that however for this I immediately saw
for myself oh yeah I could see myself
making mistakes being overly generous
towards a certain personality type you
say the certain certain three key
phrases and I'm all in um and I'm I'm
I'm kind of repelled from these things
even though I really shouldn't be it's
actually like I don't need to be your
friend I just like if I'm investing in
you I don't need to think you're cool
and want to hang with you I just need to
be able to to understand what you're
doing and invest in it
um do you uh do you feel like you have
the same thing do you have a a thing
you're drawn to like I feel like one of
yours I'll just say it out loud is I
feel like you're drawn to people who are
very meticulous and orderly in the way
they operate like if somebody's got like
a system and like they're a stickler for
the details I feel like in your like
they go up 100 points in your book
whereas for me that doesn't really do it
that does it for me because I envy that
because that that's not my natural you
know like my wife is like like that like
I'm drawn to people who are like orderly
and systematic and disciplined like
people who wake up at 5:00 a.m. every
morning that's not me and so like I'm
really fascinated by people who like
grind really hard and are systematic and
are operational and things like that uh
i' I I get a lot of Joy being around
those people because I'm not like that
can I tell you real quick about a cool
thing because I feel like we did a bunch
of uh fluffy stuff today okay I got to
get a rant off my chest
um people are really drawn to things
that highly tactical or or um highly
like
specific
um versus and complex versus things that
are simple but might be a little bit um
Airy let me give you an example when I
was in LA we did a bunch of those
dinners with Founders and I think I said
this in my debrief but I'll I'll point
out again um people the the conversation
when inevitably go like you have a bunch
of people who all sold their company
everybody's everybody in the in the
thing is you know Successful by
traditional measures and the
conversation would always gravitate
towards two subjects like kind of Health
and Longevity uh or just like kind of
like being happy being a happier person
some sort of like life quality of life
Improvement rich guy problems rich guy
[__] because like oh I've already made
it but yeah this I feel like I'm not as
happy as I thought it would be so then
what uh you know like and the longevity
health things gives them a new like the
carrot to Chase and they kind of feel
like they neglected it while running
their company and the life quality
everybody actually just wants a high
quality of life they just don't know how
to ask the questions around it um and
what you would see was two things
somebody would say uh something like
that was just like simple and useful
they'd be like yeah you know I just like
I'm um you know before bed I don't
really use my phone I just actually kind
of review the day and think about like
you know how I did and what you know
just in general like my interactions of
the day what I might have done
differently and like you know um and I'm
like oh I do that too it's I have this
thing called revision and it's like I
just kind of see the day events of my
day and I just go back and just play
them out a little differently in my head
it's really useful and people are like
like the reaction to something like that
if you just kind of tell people like hey
you know here's a simple thing you could
do imagine what you want and what it
would feel like to have it or um think
about how your day went and just be kind
of mindful and thoughtful about like you
know versus just uh always on to the
next thing um and the reaction I would
get would be
like cool and the cool is kind of like
cool good for you like um I ain't doing
that [__] uh like you know don't tell me
to be alone with my thoughts and um then
somebody would be like yeah you know I
really I was feeling kind of you know
I've just been feeling like I'm in a
funk and so I started taking you know
six milligrams of low do no Tru alone
and then people like what what what what
is it what is it called and they're like
getting their every literally everyone
gets their phone out they start what is
it called how do you spell that I'm like
are you just gonna take this random drug
this person you've never met and they'd
be like how many milligrams was that
five is five what they say where do you
get it can I order right now before I
leave this
dinner and I'm like y'all [__]
are crazy why are people so raed to the
pill the the the complex thing you can't
even pronounce that just might do it for
you vers or you know they'd be like yeah
I I hired this um you know this
functional cognitive coach and they'd be
like what's his name does he take more
clients I here's the money like I'm like
bro have you tried like [__] writing
down like you know your thoughts for a
second like nobody wants the simple
thing like nobody wants OB thing I just
thunk it up I just I just I just Thun in
my bed and it worked D I was like hey
here's what I do um you know when I go
into a situation instead of just
reacting like oh it's kind of cold out
here so I'm uncomfortable now I feel bad
I'm you I'm a little bit bothered by
that I just decide before I go in like
you know what I want to have a um I want
to have a like like a playful experence
I want to have a laughing experience
right now and then I'll just like I was
like I decide that then I go in and I
and I have that I look for those moments
and I create that experience myself it's
pretty amazing you could just do this
you could just decide what experience
you want and then go have it and they're
like
is there okay can the next person say
like a pill that I could take like some
new neut Tropic that's G to help me like
they're like all all right CH but can I
put that in my body intravenously like
is does it come with needles or do I buy
them I'm just like y'all are insane
you're insane or this guy's like uh he's
like uh you know I um I really want to
like what's that you know this equipment
oh I bought all this exercise equipment
i'm like [__] do you walk and do you
even have 30 minutes a day he's like no
no I don't exercise I don't have time
but I bu I'm building out this home gym
and I'm building it out and like like
you know you could just do push-ups on
the floor right you don't have to first
buy $10,000 of equipment before you can
work out like there's there's no gate to
to pass you just you could literally
just do 10 things 10 push-ups right now
in fact let's do that right now and uh
people are not ready for simple action
that doesn't require like a Magic Bullet
solution and um it noys the hell out of
me I'm like are you guys in is everybody
around me insane that's how I
feel well like when people say magic
pill I definitely automatically get
interested because like I would like
that like why
don't they say shortcuts like it's a bad
thing but it's like yeah I mean if I can
get to my destination shorter and faster
I'm in thing they're not even shortcuts
literally this [__] that I was talking
about this lowd do [__] whatever it's
called n Drax Salone no dra I don't know
what it was because guess what I don't
care don't need it but I was like I was
like so does this work like if you felt
like an amazing
difference the person was like no you
have to take it for six months first for
your body to acclimate I'm like you're
getting hosed like okay honestly I don't
know what this drug does maybe it's
useful maybe it's a specific thing I'm
kind of jokes aside but I for that
person who you know got it prescribed
maybe they needed it for the other eight
bastards in the at the dinner who were
like immediately trying to order it I
was like y'all don't need this like you
don't need that right now that is not
the answer to whatever you're whatever
hole you're trying to fill right now
like there is no chance that that is the
correct First Step you should be taking
well I think we talked about like the
different types of procrastination like
the good there's actually good types of
procrastination which is like uh like
the forgetful scientist who like forgets
to like shower or like put on the right
pair of socks it's like Ah that's all
right he's doing the big things right
that's okay and then there's like the
bad type which is like making PL that
don't need to be planned or like buying
domain names or like going back and
color coding it afterwards like dude
it's okay like yeah or like in in this
case it's like buying pills when it's
like just 10,000 steps a day will will
do the trick as well um but that's
pretty funny that's a good story I I uh
I would have liked to have seen you in
that room yeah I I was just like you
guys are nuts U but okay now to satisf I
like this stuff though I like this stuff
by the way I like this stuff uh
me most because tactics change
strategies don't you know what I'm
saying like I like talking about
strategy
sometimes our software is the worst have
you heard of HubSpot see most crms are a
cobble together mess but HubSpot is easy
to adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better dude have
you been following the presidential
debates and campaign stuff that's going
on did you watch Republican debate I
watched the the clips the so everyone is
it seems like the viic is uh
wow there's two ways to say his name
that and one is the right one one is the
wrong one and you just came with a third
Vic holy holy wow it's v i v k right VI
is is the way you say so some people say
V Vic and you went you went I don't even
know where you just went dude that's
like correcting me if I say it like Lady
Gaga
so are you a big Lady Gaga fan I mean
come on he was like he was like the star
of the debate um because he's just look
at him the guy's like a debate Champion
it's like what this guy's trained to do
um but he's still pulling like you know
I don't know 10% or something like that
so I think it's all I mean I think
Donald Trump's gonna win uh but I did
want to tell you a funny thing that I
remembered when I watched that debate
you watched it oh I love watching I
don't care about politics but I love
watching fights
I would not have uh thought that I love
the debates I love the strategy of the
debates I love watching it's it's
content creation I just love watching
the strategy that these guys take into
it I couldn't care less about who gets
picked couldn't care less about their
policies because they don't care about
their policies as far as I'm concerned
um to me it's a popularity contest and I
like to see who markets themselves
better uh I think there's a lot to learn
from that but one of the things that's
uh I remembered was back in the day um I
was working at Monkey Inferno and I used
to work for a guy named Michael Burch
and Michael Burch is a very interesting
guy he has built and sold multiple
companies so he sold bio famously for
$850 million he which him and his wife
owned it so they got they own almost
whole thing yeah so it was a huge exit
for husband and wife couple before that
he had built another social network sold
for a few you know single digigit
millions of dollars so he kind of made
one sold it for few million bucks then
as soon as a non-compete ended he
created it again he's like oh now I know
what I should have done the first time
and that became the $850 million ex but
he also created birthday alarm which is
a a company that had millions of dollars
in cash flow every year so he had had
multiple uh wins very interesting guy
but ever since the big bio acquisition
he created this idea lab but he kind of
transitioned to a different phase of
Life almost he was like you know I'm not
like you know what do I care it's sort
of like yeah I Angel invest but like you
know does it really matter like kind of
already won the money game in a way
right he wouldn't say that but you could
just tell it's not like his heart was in
that is he a billionaire at this point
you think even that he's like I'm not
really a billionaire but who cares you
know like I yeah I got uh you know like
he's he's at that 510 5'11 range and
like you know those guys want to be six
foot he was like that's pretty much six
right would choose so he's like you know
he's at 800 million or 900 million or
something like that he's like I don't
know I don't really keep track does it
really matter it seems seems Seems like
overkilled to care about something like
that that's nice billionaire
response he did two interesting things
one he built a private members Club in
San Francisco so he bought a old Candy
Factory that was 60,000 square feet that
was abandoned because it needed tons of
like seismic retrofitting nobody wanted
to put in the millions of dollars it
would take to retrofit this place he did
it and he built a members Club so if you
go to San Francisco you can go to this
place called the battery and it's like
Soho house but for San Francisco um
built that thing into a real juggernaut
like it actually like to totally came to
fruition this idea that seemed kind of
crazy and he had no experience in he had
never done Hospitality never done any of
that stuff one time I went there and I
saw a booth of three people and it was a
b like imagine a monk wearing like the
the Daly Lama like orange outfit like he
was baldheaded and sandals with like a
black guy that looked like a rapper like
he had like gold chains on and like sick
shoes and then this blond haired lady
and they were all leading in having a
conversation and I was like this is just
the funniest place I've ever been to
that's like the start of a joke a monk a
rapper and a and Cheryl Sandberg walking
into a
bar like no but that's what I mean I saw
Leonardo DiCaprio there uh you know tons
of famous Elon Musk a bunch of famous
people go there anyways so he that was
one thing he did but he always had these
like random ideas and once in a while he
would just be like Sean I'd like to I
have an idea for you and he would pitch
me this idea and one of the ideas he had
was around the presidential debate he
goes you know Trump got elected in I
think what 2016
he he was thinking about it for 2020 he
was like you know I think there's a good
chance that Trump gets reelected
again and he's like you know if you
think about why a lot of people in
silika Valley don't really fully you
know they're like they take these like
you know strong stances on what it means
what you know is it because part of
America feels repressed and they're
reacting to the to the LI liberal neocon
they start making up all these words
he's like I don't know if it's that as
much as it is that Donald Trump was the
more charismatic candidate and he's like
if you go back and you look throughout
time he's like in every debate or sorry
every race um if you go back to the last
like 12
elections which is like you know 50
years or something like that the more
charismatic candidate tends to win not
always but tends to win and they're
usually like tall not ugly people yeah
he's just like the more charismatic
candidate wins as simple as that right
like maybe you're charismatic because
you're really good looking and you're
you know uh maybe it's that maybe it's
that you got The Gift of Gab and you're
like you know maybe an Obama or Reagan
or something like that um you know
Clinton you know somebody who is is just
seen as very very Charming uh people
people always felt that about Bill
Clinton um so he's like you know the
more charismatic candidate tends to win
even though um you know there are other
reasons why you might pick you know why
I pick John krey over George Bush um
actually George Bush is the more
charismatic candidate versus uh John
krey or Al Gore or whatever it is and um
so he's like you know I think that given
that that's the case uh he's like I
don't think that should be the case but
I think it is I don't think he G be able
to change that he goes I feel like what
the Democrats should do is they need to
put forward the most charismatic
candidate they can and I would say he
turned out to be wrong in that they put
Joe Biden who's one of the least
charismatic candidates and he won almost
because the vote was basically Donald
Trump or not Donald Trump so I actually
think it was a bit of anomaly I actually
think he was correct uh and you're
seeing this right now DeSantis has more
experience had the machine behind him
had the track record but he's just not
charismatic he doesn't have that that je
he doesn't have that sauce and so a guy
like VI can come out and he's a better
talker he's more uh he's got more energy
he's got better onliners zingers he's
willing to take stands that will draw
attention to him and he's the more
charismatic candidate he's he's driving
up um so Michael's idea was let's create
a TV show he's like you know just like
the way we did uh American Idol and we
did you know The Apprentice why don't uh
why isn't there a show called the
president and we literally just cast
people who want to be the president but
we give them an Avenue he's like because
right now the candidates all come from
the machine it's like you know the party
is going to kind of push their favorite
candidates forward and this is based on
some you know how controllable they are
how likable they are how uh much time
they put in into the party he's like I
don't think that's necessarily putting
the strongest candidate forward
especially if you looked at this most
charismatic candidate um so he's like
why don't you create he's like why don't
we create a show that's going to take 12
hopefuls and it tells their story the
show works almost like a Survivor or
Apprentice every week they go to a new
city maybe they go to some coal mining
place in wherever West Virginia and
they're going to talk to the coal miners
and there's sort of a challenge like
they have to prepare a speech or or uh
talking points for what they would do
for to help those people and then those
people kind of vote off the weakest
candidate at the end you're left with
the most charismatic candidate and he's
like that would be a a challenger to
whoever the Democratic part is naturally
going to put up and I loved this idea I
was like this is a crazy idea this and
he's like yeah my friend Mark Bernett
who created Survivor like he could be
the producer of this and and you know we
could put this together this way and you
know even if it doesn't work like you
know I think it would just be like a
worthwhile attempt and a and an
entertaining way to do this versus like
if I really want to get involved in
politics the reason I don't don't is
that's a sort of a very uh like it's not
you know it's a laborious and sort of
painful Endeavor this would be almost a
fun version of like a way to try to to
know bring some influence to it um what
do you think of this idea that uh that I
just remembered did it go anywhere or is
he just goofing around he Al so he wrote
a
memo and it was a very well-written memo
is that the rich guy version of buy the
domain
name yeah yeah he wrote a wrote a memo
he showed it to me and I'm like yeah
this is great and I think he was like
okay if I'm going to do this this is
going to take some real kind of like
Social Capital to
do and I think he kind of was like H
Maybe not maybe my life is amazing as is
um that's his version of like when the
remote is just a little bit too far when
you're lay down and you're like ah I'll
sleep with the TV on
yeah but I've love this idea and I'm
saying it
because hey I think that more business
people should apply their kind of
creative and entrepreneurial talents
outside of just creating yet another
business so I liked that he was taking
his creative and entrepreneurial Spirit
to be like oh how could I what if I did
a TV show that would influence politics
I thought that was cool and I think more
people should do that the second reason
is I kind of wish this idea existed and
I totally think this would work if
somebody created it so what's funny is
like because you and I've I've I've I've
complim to do with this but this is
actually a criticism at this point uh
for this particular Point compliment s
par special I don't even know what that
meant should I prepare myself for a
compliment or an insult just tell me
that the compliment was that you're
WorryFree and like you're pretty
optimistic and you always like default
like oh that person they're not trying
to do anything bad here comes the [__]
slap but in this case when I hear this
I'm like um but I want like my president
to like know what they're doing and not
just be able to like be a a good speech
Giver uh and so dude that's what we have
now you think you think Joe Biden knows
what he's doing the guy's not even alive
well I'm not saying what I know works
and what I know doesn't work I'm just
saying that like my romantic view is
like well that would be it would be also
nice if they knew what they were talking
about rather than just good at talking
yeah your take on this is like wouldn't
it be cool if we just let the most
charismatic person run away with it well
you know I think you could design the
challenges to actually get them force
them to
think on the spot or perform uh in terms
of figuring out solutions to real
problems um or like putting forth what
their solutions would be in a way that's
not just prepared by handlers who have
talking points and they're going to
avoid the issue or false promises or
whatever like these people that would be
in this uh you could design the weekly
challenge to bring out whatever it is
that you want obviously people fall in
love with the characters that's how all
reality TV works you fall in love with
the characters however you could fall in
love with them as they're trying to do
certain things in the same way that they
Apprentice would test you for can you
figure out how to sell can you figure
out how to organize a project or manage
a plan um I think you could put people
through a battery of weekly challenges
that are not just are you good at
kissing babies and shaking hands but
like you know that's part of it but the
there could be other parts of it that um
you know the show decides is like you
know what are the attributes that a
president needs or the qualities or what
do we wish we could see them doing to be
able to assess their uh abilities I
think the cynical person would say well
we should look at their track record
serving in government yeah cool but that
doesn't happen that's not really what
that's not really what happens it's not
really what works if that worked you
know Trump would never have beaten
Hillary she had spent her whole life in
politics she had she was by far on paper
the more qualified candidate but America
didn't get to see that they didn't get
to appreciate that uh all they saw was
what gets put forward today which is
debates and campaigning on social media
or on TV there's this funny story about
JFK when do you remember like uh what
the Cold War was you know it was in the
60s where like we thought that Soviet
Union and America were going to like
bomb each other yeah there's this story
where JFK John Kennedy goes to um Soviet
Union and he meets with the president or
the leader of Soviet Union and at the
end of the meeting this the the leader
was like you know you're you're a really
nice person you kind of reminded me of
my son I guess like we could be we could
be cool like you know you seem you seem
kind and I read that story and I was
like oh I guess like charisma really
does matter a whole lot when it comes to
like diplomatic stuff like just being
likable and being like hey let's just
calm down let be friends it definitely
Ison Robin tells the story I don't know
if this is real or not but who was the
do you know who who was the president
during the Cold War is
that well Kennedy Kennedy for Cold War
was a long period but Kennedy was like
when we thought that we were literally
gonna bomb each other okay there was I
don't I feel like it wasn't cidate he
was talking about but Tony Robbins tells
the story he goes I was I had a chance
to talk to former president who whoever
let's just pretend I know and care about
presidential history sure and he's like
uh the Cold War was happening and he
went to go see I think it was cold war
people who actually know about this are
gonna you you have full permission to
beat me up in the comments so he goes to
see gorbachov and um they have a meeting
and the meeting is not going well the
Hope was we could deescalate but
actually the meeting was sort of like
tension um and like neither side wanted
to give and they were sort of getting
more dug in more stubborn in their
stance and this is uh this would be
Reagan Ronald Reagan Reagan all my
married man out there know when this
happens you think you're going into
deescalate but actually both sides are
what s par calls dug in and the tension
is escalating he doesn't know really
what to do and he goes he goes how did
you do it how did he's like something
happened in that meeting that worked
what was it he goes well we hit that
point I said this is not going to work
and I got up and I walked out of the
room fast stormed out of the room and
right before I got to the door I hit him
with a little 360 turned back big smile
on my face said let's start over smil on
his face shook his hand and said I'm you
I'm Ronald and you know I really
appreciate these things about you and he
like Turned he just basically like you
know broke the frame for a second and
used a little bit of Charisma a little
bit of playfulness in order to reduce
tension and then they had a conversation
now I have no idea if the story is true
Tony Robbins told me this I believed it
in the moment because it's a great story
and who why let the truth get in the way
of a good story um if it is true that's
unbelievable if it's partially true
that's really cool if it's totally made
up ah whatever uh you know it's okay
still the story still serves his purpose
it is a very useful technique to be able
to do this to be able to use a little
bit of Charisma and playfulness in order
to diffuse a situation or to uh to break
through any like Deadlocks that that
exist whether it's in business or in
personal
so either Vic is just not charismatic or
I'm an idiot but let me tell you a
really quick story I have um so I've
turned down two presidential candidates
to either come on this pod or speak at
my events the first one was Andrew uh
what's his name Yang the guy the math
guy so he emailed me I think in
2015 being like hey I want to come speak
at your event and I don't know if the
podcast existed then but he's like or if
you guys want to write about me in the
newsletter I'd love to do interview you
know I I run this study test prep
company it did okay and now I'm running
for president and I was like oh you're
insane you're you're like you're gonna
make me look like a fool just this
nobody guy who run a mediocre business
uh running for president I can't
interview you like that that hurt my my
credibility Well turns out he was a
serious candidate at least he made it in
the top 10 or whatever the second time
this happened was viic viic viic Lady
Gaga it's not it's not
is it not called faag it's fetas fajitas
um so vivec dm'd me on Twitter like a
year ago and he was like hey would you
guys want me to come on the Pod and I
spped on him hard I thought this was
because he had a really his Twitter
picture was him in a suit with a nice
smile stuff it nerd you're not coming on
the
podcast well and I think like I was like
researching Martin scarelli and I was
like oh this and his bio said he was in
BIO like uh pharmaceutical industry or
something like that and I was like oh
this guy's a Charon like he's so
good-looking he's got a nice smile this
is like a crypto guy with abs and a
Ferrari like I can't take this guy
seriously and I just said what do you
want to talk about like and I Tred to
like stiff arm him to like make him
prove himself and he replied and I
ignored him turns out you know a year
and a half two years later he's actually
a threat so this is the second
presidential candidate that I've had bad
judgment on of whether they're going to
be serious and not asking them to come
on the Pod yeah yeah totally uh totally
with you I'm by the way for high
entertainment do you subscribe to Ronda
Sis's SMS program no no so if you want
to learn about marketing or you want to
learn how the presidential race really
works go subscribe to all the candidates
um marketing emails and text messages
warning it's [__] annoying okay so
that's the first
problem if I wanted somebody to text me
every day I'd have a girlfriend and uh
this guy texts you all the time and they
text the dumbest stuff so like here I'm
just going to read you the last five
texts if you think this guy's like some
super serious politician who's really
making it a substantive race about the
issues here's what he's saying and was
it like five in one day text yesterday
yeah exactly yeah yesterday 4:21 p.m.
new shirts shirt Emoji new Koozies new
cups new buttons new stickers new hats
if you haven't seen our storefront go
get the hottest limited edition campaign
merch here okay that's say yesterday
okay cool let's go back friend friend
it's Ronda santis this is now the day
before 2 2:08 p.m. friend it's Ronda
santis I want you to know that as
president I will not let the Government
weaponize Federal Agencies against
Americans who dare to disagree I'm
disgusted by the FBI's disgraceful act
labeling Catholics as
extremist I it's time to fire the FBI
director and defend Liberty religious
liberty for all can I have a donation to
have your
support okay so that's the that's the
next one here we go again um let me find
it uh particular he just text me at 7:19
a.m. it's too early for a text Ron
enough with the talk Americans need
action and that's what Ronda santis is
all about I'm the leader you need this
the time to act is now this can't wait
Rush your support in link to his
donation Campa link to his donation then
another one hey like this like this
credential and he puts a picture of a
like a credit card that just says dan
santis on it he goes you could have your
own all caps donation with with 47 or
more to join my investor team if you're
an investor in this campaign you'll have
everything you need to show it off grab
your membership card today it just
continues every single day hey enter
this giveaway to come to the next debate
you just have to donate and you can win
a VIP experience um it just keeps going
like and it'll just be like uh hey
friend I'm out here draining the swamp
right now and it's like dude just stop
like what are you talking about well
they're building like a billion- dollar
company in like 18 months they're like a
moving company you ever notice how like
moving companies like they don't give a
[__] about the service because like
you're only going to use it once and
they're like let me just get you a board
gotcha [__] and then they's like throw
your [__] there they're like dude we
don't give it like renewals aren't a
thing here I don't care you know I mean
I I hired this service that was like um
it was called like muscle head movers or
something like that and all of the
imagery all of the imagery was just the
huge like buff guys it was like hey we
make it easy we'll move that couch we'll
move that fridge no problem just another
day at the gym for us so I'm like oh
hell yeah Tire muscle head
movers three tiny Vietnamese guys showed
up and I was like and the the truck said
muscle head movers and I was
like got him I'm looking at him and I'm
just are you going to say anything are
you going to address this friend and
they didn't and I didn't cuz I was like
what am I supposed to say here and I was
like want a bunch of greas up punks
hoping and they did the job like they
could move everything because they just
used dollies and I was like oh if I
wanted Dolly movers I would have you
know like it's different it's a
different experience than I signed up
for that
catfished that's so stupid um there's uh
there is one cool thing I wanted to to
tell you about all right what is it
there's a guy named Seth Bannon who
tweeted this out he goes um two million
scient ific papers are published each
year that's over 5,000 a day even if
you're working 10 hours a day no breaks
you'd have to read one paper every seven
seconds just to keep up so we built
paper scraper to like basically
programmatically read every paper that
comes out um but not just every single
paper we prioritize and wait any paper
that's being shared by top scientists on
social media so basically built a thing
that makes it easier to keep up with
science and uh he's the second person
I've seen d this and I'm actually like
pretty convinced it's actually just a
good product idea so what's the uh
what's the URL do you know because it's
so new it doesn't show up on Google
there's not a a website for it yet he's
like oh like we built this for ourselves
but like I'll let some people in beta if
you fill out this type form you know
like that sort of thing like soft launch
I would love to see our buddy um leor
who does alpha signals so this guy built
like a uh you know like a AI newsletter
thing but his AI newsletter has one key
difference which is instead of just
telling jabronies like what the new chat
GPT feature is it's basically a AI
newsletter that's for technical people
so if you're a researcher you're a
machine learning engineer you're a um a
PhD type person Alpha signal is a
newsletter for those people which I
actually think is a very smart way to
approach this business because that's a
very high value reader and customer and
for them he provides a very simple
service so he also built a thing like
this internally so what he did was he
goes all right every paper has uh you
know a list of scientists uh that are
like the researchers that were involved
and actually there's a a nameing
convention just like in movies the
credits like the F the stars go first
and the people at the back were like
kind of the end credits in research
papers it's kind of the same thing the
people at the top did all the work the
last person is like the the Nam person
who reviewed it or edited at the end or
stamped you know their seal of approval
on it or the lab they're associated with
so he kind of first created a a a page
rank of researchers and scientists this
is awesome then he's like cool now when
a paper comes out that has one of them
in the name or those people on social
media share a paper I immediately know
this is probably an interesting paper so
that first creates a Hit List he gets
alerted like alert top scientist a Shar
page page rank is what Google invented
it's how they know what to show up on
the top of Google page rank is
categorized like there's a bunch of
different measurements the biggest
measurement or they don't even tell
people but it's theorized or maybe they
even said this though but which is how
many people link back to your website
yeah how many other reputable websites
linked to yours so every every website
has Authority so let's say New York
Times has a high Authority compared to
sean.com right and so if New York Times
links to some other website that tells
Google that that other website might be
uh and also a high Authority site it
increases its Authority if Sean links to
it it increases it a teeny tiny tiny
amount and so that's how Google
basically figured out what's the right
you know what's the right web page to
show when I when you search a question
who's who has the most authority to to
give you the answer so um this guy uh
for Alpha signal leor did this for for
scientific papers so he's like who are
the top scientists what are they sharing
what are they linking to if they're
linking to something that's an important
paper or an interesting paper they you
take the interesting paper feed it
through his llm and it gets summarized
down into four bullet points like what
was the What did the what was the
finding what was the methodology who are
the scientists and what's the kind of
like key uh takeaways from from this an
alpha signal is only for like AI topic
correct but I'm like dude this is a
generalized product that's actually just
really interesting like your I was like
your method to create this newsletter is
more interesting to me than the
newsletter itself yeah yeah yeah and
paper scraper is the same idea just from
a different guy approaching it from a
slightly different angle which was same
thing like basically trying to figure
out what are the important papers that
are coming out so of the of the two
million papers or of the 5,000 that are
published every day which three should I
care about which five should I care
about
and then of the five that I care about
what did they actually mean and what do
they say yeah they're really hard to
read hard to read so I think this is a
really really cool product idea and then
he also built like a thing called spin
out GPT which was basically like you can
it's like chat GPT you can ask it
questions about things that might like
you know could we commercialize uh this
and or like would this work in a Cell C
culture or tissue and then it'll go look
in the paper and find did they do it in
cell culture or tissue and it'll answer
uh that way so it's almost like being
able to talk to research papers or talk
to talk to a very smart person that read
all of the research papers and it's like
oh I see where this is going like you
know the hustle milk Road these were
like um the horse carriages right like
yeah we have random humans trying to
keep up with what's going on maybe they
set up some Google Alerts so they check
Reddit and Twitter and every day they
make a list and we talk about it and
then they read it and summarize and they
summarize it as good as they can
and then like you know the pitch was
like it's like your smart friend
explaining what happened in crypto that
day or yours was it's like your smart
friend explaining what happened in
business news that day and this is like
this is like your [__] genius friend
that read every scientific paper ever
and you can ask it any question in any
variation and it will answer you're like
well that seems pretty powerful huh like
if we're on our horseback and just like
a car just flew by whoa what the hell
was that but what about my friend Greg
he
uh no I by the way I'm happy we I I
would not want to be in the newsletter
business right now it which is so funny
because everybody's following us into
the newsletter businesses now like now
he's like Peak hype on newsletters and
also the way that people are acquiring
users like I just subscribed to Seth
band and substack and like right after I
subscribed it said do you want to
subscribe to these 18 other newsletters
and it's Auto checked and I almost
accidentally clicked like yes it's like
and they're all like whoa look at my
newsletter growth it's insane and it's
like dude anyone on subst that's talk
about your newsletter growth you're full
of [__] is my my answer to you like you
are absolutely full of [__] it's like
people think they're feeling out a
capture and they're actually subscribing
to 19 newsletters like at a time it's
insane that's why you know what I like
beehive has a good feature they did a
feature like that that's actually legit
which is their thing was you can you
have to manually be like who do I want
to endorse but also they have this thing
what it's called like Sparks or some
[__] like that but it's like you can pay
to acquire newsletter subscribers like
all of us know the best newsletter
subscrib you can get is somebody who
already subscribes to other newsletters
that are similar but that's really hard
to get historically because you have to
advertise in like a hundred different
newsletters so they created a little
mini ad Network inside uh inside beehive
of all the Beehive newsletters but
what's cool about it was you only pay
for somebody who's a retained reader and
I was like oh okay that's actually legit
so instead of just like this like Auto
Che vanity metric where it's like hey I
got more subscribers but it's like are
they actually an Engaged reader you have
no idea but you're you're excited about
that anyway anyways what I like that
bive did was you only pay it's like you
know CPA versus CPM or CPC it's like CPA
is like you only pay for a reader you
actually acquired who's still reading
from you and um and so enforces quality
because that's the only way you get
rewarded in that Network so I was like
that's smart first of all this Seth
Bandon thing is awesome I just I the
tweet that Sean's referring to is from
June 12 so if you Google Seth Bannon and
go to his thing it was on June 12th
that's awesome he filmed the video in
like in a amazing Place uh like it looks
like a TED Talk almost but like with
like an IMAX style screen explaining his
concept I don't know if that would be a
good business I'm I'm nervous about
people building businesses right now on
top of open AI because I'm like they're
just going to crush everyone and just do
it themselves but this is awesome and
second yeah to to reiterate I'm happy
I'm not doing a newsletter as my main
thing right now it seems really really
hard and like I remember at the hustle
we had one daily newsletter and then
morning Brew's um strategy was to launch
more but my thing was like [__] but if
we have more our main thing was going to
go down like they're not going to open
two they're not going to open three now
people if the numbers are true are
subscribing to dozens and I want to know
is the engagement even remotely the same
it seems really really really hard it
seems way harder yeah I think it's a lot
like podcasts like how many podcasts do
you actually have in a regular rotation
any given time yeah it seems hard I mean
with News letters it's easier because it
only takes three minutes to skim it but
it seems really hard to get people's
attention with the newsletter right now
it's just so funny when we so I got the
idea for a newsletter because I had my
friend Neville madora and my other
friend Noah Kagan they were like they
had one foot into the startup world one
foot into like the internet marketing
world and I was like oh this internet
marketing World they love email and they
use it in sometimes Shady ways but let's
just see if we can do it a legit way and
people are like laughing at that now
it's so cool but but also that that
people take it seriously but I'm so
happy I'm not doing it it seems way more
challenging at the moment I uh it it
seems really hard yeah I think the best
will still win um because you know the
best tends to win and everything um like
you know so so it's not that the do
actually closed um but it's definitely
much harder than when you started you
when did you start 2015
2016 yeah it I got the idea of doing a
newsletter and I started it in 2014 but
it became what it was in uh on May 19th
2016 a great day in history well I
always remember that because it's the
day before 420 uh so it always it was
always easy to remember um but yeah and
it was like I remember like at for I
originally started as a conference and
if I had five uh if I had 2,000
subscribers to my conference newsletter
I think I made $50,000 in conference
ticket sales and then when I had 10,000
I think we did
150,000 in ticket sales something like
that and like the engagement was quite
high and then I remember people back
then saying I think Gary vaynerchuk I
talked to him one time he was like dude
my newsletter we had a 99% open rate
because no one else was doing
newsletters yours is only 40% it's so
much harder and uh I was like oh man I
wish it was easier now I I don't know
what those numbers would be like but I
think it would be hard to make that
amount of money with as few subscribers
today as it it was easier then you know
the other thing that's funny is um or I
guess the other thing that that kind of
reminds me of is you're I wish people
would see kind of your early blog post
or you should we should do kind of like
a trip down memory lane of some of our
projects um
because you're incredibly good at
creating content and writing um we like
when I see what you did versus what I
see a lot of people doing now I'm like
oh there are like many rungs on the
ladder above is where where where you
were with creating content um back then
like I remember your early blog posts
that were just regularly going viral
getting millions of hits to the site um
because they were that good like which
ones like when you were doing the got
you like first you had the right concept
so you were kind of like a YouTuber
before YouTube actually you really
should have been a YouTuber like that
would have been your calling I I believe
we got we got asked to like we were
thinking about doing it but I wasle
saying s par as a YouTuber would have
been I believe like you would have been
one of the most successful YouTubers on
the platform let me give you an example
that's awesome you're like for example I
remember some of your early hustle blog
posts uh surviving 30 days on soy lent
only guess what that sounds like every
Ryan trean video every Mr Beast video
like this is this is the current meta of
YouTube you were doing this eight years
ago you know like it was you were wa uh
you did micro doing LSD you did an
interview with a Anonymous entrepreneur
who um whoes books yeah yeah you did the
the the thing where you were like Amazon
bestsellers are [__] I'm gonna prove
it by making an Amazon bestseller
spending only like a$ thousand dollars
guess what that's a YouTube video These
Are YouTube videos they would these
videos would still work but the thing
is you have to do them with style you
actually did the thing with style now
you your problem was you were locked
into this blog world because those are
the people you admired at the time the
real I knew how to write you know like
writing was my thing I wasn't I don't
know if I could have maybe I could had
the visual aesthetic too like you're
good on camera you like lived in a
freaking you like lived on a motorcycle
or something I don't know you sleeping
on a motorcycle you're doing some crazy
[__] it's like you had the dog and you
had the look and you had the the humor
on camera and you were willing you you
liked jackass and those sorts of things
and I feel like you would have kind of
tortured yourself for people's
entertainment as soon as you got that
hit of feedback you would have gone all
the way in wish you had kind of gone
down that route in fact I still think
you should go down that route like for
example I think I can be successful in
fact I'm going to be successful on short
form video but it's not going to be the
way you could have been because you're
kind of like those like you know whoever
this Danny Duncan and uh and Ryan Tran
and and and you know Mr be you're a lot
like them in the the way that you are as
a character and what you're willing to
do and what you were willing to do and
how long you were kind of like I'm
single and don't give a [__] and like I
don't need comfort and like you know oh
like this firecracker is going to go in
my ass all right let's roll like you
know lights action right like I think
that you had all of that and so um
anyways I don't know what my point I
don't wish I would have gone that by the
way I don't I I think I think I I think
I probably could have done it I think
that that's a hard life I think it's
hard like I like Danny Duncan a lot but
I'm like can you do that at 40 I guess
it just has to change it has to evolve
or like Mr Beast what's he going to do
at 40 he's going to be so wealthy
doesn't really matter yeah I you would
have done the same yeah but um yeah like
our early blog posts were good and there
was a period where I was writing like
five a day um I would write so many of
them not all of them were bangers but
like we would write a ton and that's how
we grew and that's why I tell people I
say to blog I don't actually mean blog
but I meant create
bangers text based bangers uh on a
consistent basis and get people to love
your free content enough to subscribe
TBB baby text based
bangers that's been our strategy right
like how' you like for me um when we
wanted to grow on Twitter it was like
all the advice was you got to be
consistent well guess what I'm like the
least consistent human being on earth
like if you weren't super consistent and
a real hard ass about like we're gon to
record this every Monday every Wednesday
9:00 am every single every single week
without fail no matter what there's no
way I would keep up this schedule right
like I only do that because you're my
friend I don't want to let you down the
when I'm on my own I'm inconsistent and
when I wanted to grow on Twitter I was
like look all the conventional wisdoms
you got to tweet every day multiple
times a day find the right time of the
day be consistent be on brand have a
single message do a call to action I'm
like dude I ain't trying to do all that
that sounds like hard sounds like the
lame version of success and um I agree
it's probably right but like I didn't
want to do it that way and my way was
text based bangers it's like I basically
had like six viral tweets That Grew me
to like almost 400,000 followers just it
was literally just six tweets basically
that the bulk of the grow like the club
one the metaverse one this one about
Elon Musk this other one it's just like
that's all it was that that got me like
kind of all the growth and then just's
like several weeks in between posts I'm
completely inconsistent well what I told
people was like my team and like myself
when I was starting the hos I was like
you know everyone says it's a marathon
not a Sprint but you're kind of just
telling me that you just don't want to
work that hard and if you look at the
worldclass marathoners that's going to
feel like a Sprint to most people so
that's just kind of like how we're going
to live our life which is is like it is
a marathon and it's run so fast that
it's going to feel like a Sprint to most
people this a marathon not a Sprint but
we're Kenyon and so we're going Five
Mile my last pretend yeah your last name
is Kip chogi you know you're gonna be a
Kenyan yeah you could be a belli you're
an Ethiopian but you know like we're
East Africans here baby we're gonna run
fast and
uh yeah I think um but I actually I
prefer writing I think that it's more
fun to be in a quiet Zone late at night
and just bang it out and it feels a
little bit more Artful uh it felt like I
was in my zone of Genius a little bit
whereas with video it feels like
sometimes you have to perform and I felt
that writing was a different type of
performance that is more enjoyable to
create for me yeah
sure dude surprise surprise man likes
his choices and defends them
by the way look at my Shir person thinks
that what they did was the correct thing
shocker I I did live life look at me
when I was fat and selling hot dogs man
I was about I was about I was that
YouTube life it just you know without
the
camera I was telling Sarah I was like
I'm nervous about going to Westport or
like Connecticut or like if we're gonna
move to the suburbs and she's like why I
was like well what am my favorite things
to do is like so every day I like to go
to this gas station near my house and
get a DI Dr Pepper and loer like I just
like yeah I get a slip JY and a Diet
pepper and I'll like dab it up with like
the clerk and then I'll just sit and see
the regulars like what's up man redell
what's good how are you like I just like
to loiter like do hood rat [__] man yeah
and I was like Connecticut doesn't have
like hood rats or they people that pump
your gas yeah what am I gonna do like
where like I want to watch people buy
lottery tickets and scratch offs and
like like smoke like a miles like where
am I going to hang out with like I need
that smell of like the woods they call
it you know like the uh the Blunts and
uh where am I going to do that you know
like that's how you get like good ideas
and you like see interesting people so
yeah think about how many incredible
podcasters there are that just don't
podcast but they just chop it up sitting
on steps like all day just talking
around people that come by like can you
imagine how good those people would be
if we just put a mic in front of them
they just don't know like they're just
they're just like you know it's like
those like kids who are like incredible
basketball players somewhere in afca
that we just don't know we haven't found
them yet like just imagine the dudes
that just stood on the steps all day
just shooting the [__] that like jogan
is lucky those guys don't have a
microphone and they just like sit
outside of a gas station like read
newspapers I always be funny I always
thought it' be funny if you like walk up
and you overhear their conversation and
they're like dog you better diversify
your bonds man like the Dow's down like
are just having like the most academic
conversations ever because they read
newspapers all
day
all right I think we've uh I think we've
crossed crossed the
threshold the slab happy face is
initiated all right that's the pod